Game of Thrones fans have a rough
understanding of the night Kings origins
and mission there's still so much to dig
into as to why he did what he did
whether he might rise again and just how
he planned to take over the world beyond
Winterfell the night Kings story begins
with the story of Westeros before the
first men came the children of the
forest lived in harmony with the Giants
though they forged no metal they
developed dragonglass
or as we know it obsidian into useful
tools and arrowheads and developed their
unique magic unfortunately for them the
first men invaded the children's land
across a then intact land bridge from
Essos
they brought bronze masses of people and
a thirst for conquest though the
children's magic was strong enough to
shatter the land bridge and separate the
two continents it proved no match for
the sheer numbers and sturdy metal
weaponry brought by the first men in a
last-ditch attempt to save their way of
life the children drove a dragonglass
dagger into a captured first man and
used their magic to transform him into
an undead being of ice the night King
first of his kind had been born into a
world uh turley unprepared for his
bottomless bloodlust though the children
and the first men did ultimately end
their hostilities the night King and his
undead disciples known as White Walkers
had become creatures of entirely alien
purpose Game of Thrones never supplied
any specifics as to when the night king
turned his forces against warm-blooded
life nor even how long precisely their
icy reign lasted what is known is that
the night King and his army of undead
invaded northern Westeros and an entire
generation suffered and died within the
seemingly endless winter they brought
this became known as the long night
marked by the failure of crops massive
casualties by the sword starvation and
sickness alike complete darkness and the
destruction of organised settlements it
was in the end the closest the night
king ever came to succeeding in his goal
of wiping out all life and his brand
stars later pointed out on
memory of life as well though the night
King in the White Walkers never advanced
beyond Westeros their terror became
legendary they were ultimately pushed
back to the polar wasteland through an
enormous conjoint effort of magic luck
and engineering referred to as the war
for the dawn bran the Builder an
ancestor of House Stark erected a 700
foot tall barrier known as the wall
through a powerful blend of magic and
science so that the blue-eyed Menace
might never return millennia passed
during which the night King and the
walkers became a long-ago threat a
distant peril and finally a story meant
to frighten children in the dead of
night perhaps this was an intentional
ploy on the part of the night king whose
immortality meant he could wait a long
time for his opportunity to strike the
long night had given way to the dawn and
the night King bided his time for 8,000
years at some point in the decades
before the events of Game of Thrones the
night King demanded a tribute from the
wildlings male infants as revealed in
the season 4 episode of keeper they were
taken to the lands of always winter laid
upon icy altars and turned into White
Walkers by the night King himself the
process is apparently simple yet notably
enigmatic it's a different process than
we see when the night King raises
corpses as white but we never learn how
often it was done if every Walker had
the power to do this nor how many human
infants were turned over the course of
the eight thousand year retreat like so
many things about the night king and his
subjects this horrifying element would
remain a mystery once he had gathered
whatever number of corpses and infant
sacrifices that he thought would be
enough to conquer Westeros the night
King sent out his forces to harass
murder and generally terrorized the
wildlings one especially horrible
manifestation of this campaign makes up
the first scene of the show's very first
episode recall the Nights Watch deserter
beheaded by Ned Stark the artfully
arranged circle of corpse parts and the
dark shadow that would be all the
audience saw of the walkers until the
season 2 finale Westeros remained
largely ignorant of the threat
some were not so lucky the walkers were
making a statement and the night King
showed no interest in pulling back as
the rumors grew in fact it's likely that
he was very purposefully looking to sow
that sort of fear as the wildlings grew
more terrified
the Nights Watch grew divided as to how
to deal with them dissent festered
culminating in Jon Snow's murder and the
mutiny against Lord Commander Mormont
the humans had been turned against
themselves and all the night King had to
do was be there to turn the corpses into
his army years passed over the course of
the first five seasons of Game of
Thrones while the night King gathered
his strength the Nights Watch came to
understand the White Walkers as a clear
and present danger finally realizing
that they were up against thousands of
corpses raised to fight against the
living it all came to a head in season
fives hard home hard home was the
closest thing the wildlings ever had to
a city it's where Jon Snow
tormund Giantsbane and a handful of
nights Watchmen and like-minded
wildlings traveled to urge its denizens
to join them in the fight against the
walkers but their best laid plans went
belly-up when the walkers attacked just
as the wildling boats set to sail to the
wall were beginning to fill an avalanche
of whites over ran the crude settlements
slang thousands in a savage surge of
brutality in the midst of the slaughter
Jon Snow discovered Valyrian steel
resiliency against Walker ice magic and
immediately after its ability to shatter
the beings themselves those fighting on
the side of the Living might have
learned something crucial about Valyrian
steel but it came at a terrible cost
while Jon Snow and the Nights Watch were
battling the walkers that sword and
shield bran stark was on a crusade of
his own learning to harness his psychic
powers emboldened he entered a vision
only to be spotted by the night king who
was able to grab brand's arm across
miles of distance and brand it with his
mark he can't get it
you can now despite hodor's tragic
sacrifice and the children's magic the
walkers were not stopped though the
three-eyed Raven was able to pass on his
powers to Brant he still fell to the
night
spear along with many of what might have
been the only children of the forest
left and stripping bran of his most
important allies protectors and teachers
managed to further that goal
considerably as the night King neared
the wall Jon Snow proposed something
drastic gathering a party of warriors to
capture a wight that would prove the
truth of the threat to Queen Cersei and
her skeptical Court though the grizzled
band was in fact able to present the
Queen with a real-deal blue-eyed corpse
it came at tremendous cost the walkers
and their army killed much of the group
including Viserion one of Daenerys
Targaryen x' trio of dragons the fact
that Cersei didn't join forces with
Daenerys and John in the war against the
Walkers is cruel enough but even worse
the night King was able to raise
Viserion as an undead dragon complete
with the ability to breathe massively
destructive blue fire Jon Snow might
have accomplished what he set out to do
in the most literal sense but on a much
more important scale this was yet
another victory for the night King the
army of death had only grown in its size
and sinister capabilities the night king
is coming the dead are already here it
wasn't long before the night king
decided to put his brand new steed to
the test
leading untold thousands of resurrected
corpses a host of mounted White Walkers
and a fearsome number of undead beasts
the night King descended upon the castle
of eastwatch-by-the-sea with frozen fury
one fiery assault from Vissarion was all
it took to pierce the wall thousands of
tons of enchanted ice rock and masonry
fell beneath the eerie blue flame
leaving a clear road through to Westeros
it was this shocking image that closed
out the seventh season finale of Game of
Thrones the last best defense of the
living torn asunder
at last the wall which had stood for
8,000 years had fallen before the night
King and his seemingly unstoppable army
all he had left to do was Massacre his
prey starting with Winterfell and all
the living souls who dwelt within the
night
King advanced upon the north quickly his
first stop was the last hearth the home
of house umber though battered by the
war and tasked with maintaining a remote
position between the unknown wastes and
the comforts of Winterfell umber was a
proud house with a long and glorious
history in the aftermath of the Battle
of the bastards the house was headed by
Lord Ned umber a 10 year old looking to
regain the honor lost when his family
back to the Bolton's will you stand
beside me Ned now unfortunately the
night came made that always quite a bit
shorter than it should have been the
last hearth was the walker's first stop
on the way to Winterfell and after
slaughtering Ned umber and his household
they left a grim warning behind in the
form of their characteristic spiral of
body parts though Ned was prevented from
causing more carnage as a white courtesy
of a flaming sword killing umber stands
as one of the saddest crimes the night
King perpetrated with the wall breached
the Army's mast a dragon risen from the
grave and the living forces of Westeros
getting their hands on every ounce of
dragonglass that they could there was no
time for preparation instead it was war
the night King descended upon Winterfell
like a tempest swallowing the fires of
Dothraki warriors trenches of flame
valiant charges alike within his icy
darkness beyond the mayhem and death
that he brought with him the night King
had a mission to find bran stark the new
three-eyed raven and kill him brand new
this and allowed himself to be used as
bait the stakes were high Theon Greyjoy
died in his efforts to protect bran the
dead in the crypts and on the
battlefields of Winterfell were raised
by the knight Kings powers and Jon Snow
resorted to facing Vissarion with
nothing but a sword then out of nowhere
came Arya Stark honed into one of the
finest warriors alive with one swift
stab the night king was slain along with
all the creatures he'd created the army
of the Dead was gone
an eternity of winter had been avoided
and the White Walkers with the death of
their leader and progenitor instantly
became extinct thus ended the war
audiences had been teased with for years
Arya's devastatingly precise stabbed she
vanquished the white walkers completely
the night Kings reign of terror lives on
however in the hearts of Game of Thrones
principal characters Jon Snow
free at last to live beyond titles and
Great Houses cannot ever rid himself of
the evil he stared down and returns to
the Nights Watch bran elevated to King
is also tasked with remembering what
brought the walkers about in the first
place Arya
off on adventures beyond the borders of
Westeros will doubtlessly be followed
everywhere she goes by the fact of her
great world-saving deed these and many
other characters now live in a Westeros
that's as much defined by the night
Kings absence as it was by his presence
the night King might be dead but his
memory will linger on for years to come
if only as a terrifying fairy tale check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]